-And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite mom quotes
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one
is from @victoriapike.
She said...
[ Laughter ]
Close.
Chai tea.
-Use the energy.
-Yeah, she used the energy.
Coffee pours itself.
Yeah.
-You're clean.
Very slowly.
-This one's from @itsLJ.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-"Bow to Mom."
This one's from @simpovski.
She says...
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pretty good.
Oh, this is -- this is funny.
This one's from @Bethrob325.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa!
Hey-oh!
E-ticket.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
The Big D?
[ Laughter ]
-In some places,
it's a small world.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Oy!
[ Laughs ]
-This one is from @JulesRead1.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's so my mom.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
That is hilarious.
Everything
wrapped in aluminum foil.
"I don't know what it is."
-No date.
-Nope.
[ Light laughter ]
This one's from @devholla14.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-This one's from
@brennenhancock.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
Okay.
-Okay.
Then they went to Disneyland.
[ Laughter ]
Took a long trip to Disneyland.
-This last one's
from @hoorayplatypus.
She sa--
-Hooray, platypus!
[ Laughter ]
I love platypus, right?
-Hooray, platypus.
-Hooray!
-Yeah.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.